League of Legends fans couldn't have
asked for a better setup two stars on
opposing teams who started their careers
in the same year and even attended the
same school battling for League's
biggest prize nearly a decade later but
world's Grand finals went beyond the
storyline the series had plenty of
incredible moments and might be the most
exciting and emotional best of five in
world's finals history and this wasn't a
duel at dawn it was a fist fight in the
pouring rain it was the payoff at the
end of a long road for League fans and
damn does it feel good to be a league
fan right now so let's enjoy The Vibes
and take a look at this truly
exceptional world's final
foreign
[Music]
we are so close to 2 million subscribers
on YouTube and listen we'd love to have
you be a part of that so why not hit the
Subscribe button if you're not subbed
already and if you have a good time
maybe hit the like button and maybe ring
the notification Bell so you get the
next one served fresh right away like a
six dollar foot long so worlds 2022 is
done and dusted and well you probably
didn't expect a finale this incredible
now of course I'd say that because for
me these things are about storylines I
love having an excellent storyline when
I go to actually write about this and
there's a strong chance that at least
somebody will be doing so in the near
future but what we saw this past weekend
wasn't just the result of a cool story
it was an incredible culmination of a
year of League of Legends that saw
expectations shattered and new Champions
rise so let's set the stage on the one
side we have T1 and of course the
greatest of all time figure now
surrounded by budding young Stars some
of whom were developed within the T1
organization Faker was on a year-long
mission to win Worlds I feel like Danny
made at least six videos about it during
the year you know hashtag Faker watch
but at the end of the day I can't say I
blame him the hype wasn't just hype
Faker and the rest of the team made good
on their promise to get back to Worlds
and they mostly stomped opponents on the
way to get there their opponents on the
other hand well
they probably weren't a team that many
people expected to go all the way TRX
made the true Miracle run at Worlds from
their Region's fourth seed in play-ins
all the way to Grand finals it was a
historic run and their star player depth
had history with Faker the two went to
the same high school and back then def
said he had heard a rumor that a
top-ranked player was in attendance both
players also started their careers in
2013. but their two paths diverged Faker
would go on to win three World
Championships along with plenty of
domestic success Daft on the other hand
walked a very different path in 2013 his
team didn't make it out of groups at
Worlds and then in 2014 he bowed out in
semi-finals def spent two years in China
before returning to Korea and he made
worlds four more times although he never
got further than quarterfinals I guess
what I'm trying to say is that death's
story didn't exactly exactly scream
championship winner at least not the way
that Bakers did but Deft was the fifth
player to reach 300 lck wins the third
player to reach 500 lck games played and
he had seven World Championship
appearances the guy had a pedigree and
he was looking to redeem himself against
his rival Faker also he gets called the
alpaca because of his appearance which I
do think is kind of funny but wait a sec
do you hear that I can already hear the
notes from my editor screaming at me to
just get on with writing about the
actual finals so let's do it DRX did it
Deft won his first world championship
and stole the trophy away from Faker in
the last possible game
foreign
champions
untilledable
unassailable DRX world champions
this moment was the culmination of an
incredible story from play-ins to finals
becoming Champions it's never happened
before it will likely never happen again
it's unprecedented and DRX made history
the biggest storyline in the series
besides the two stars as we mentioned
and DRX winning it all with this
Cinderella run was probably what
happened in the Top Lane where Zeus t1's
top laner was expected to be a key part
of their Victory as one of if not the
best top laners in the world but instead
it was King in drx's top laner whose
will became law in the Top Lane kingan
exposed Zeus throughout the series and
he actually had some pretty incredible
highlights for himself as Faker absorbs
this wave meanwhile back in top Q three
hits the mark infernal change solo
kingdom was deservedly named MVP of this
series but t1's bot Lane was pretty hot
too carrier in particular was consistent
for his team and he was able to show his
former teammates on DRX exactly how far
he had come another arrow lands into a
full combo it's just a big chunk but
it's wow they're also getting the
objective and they have the herald as
well so they can push in these both
waves Force the RX
oh my God here we go
carry on me he just sets it up like it's
point and clear and t1's 80 carry
gumiyushi managed to steal the baron on
two separate occasions to keep desperate
situations alive for T1 area is trying
to find a little bit of vision
is gonna have to disrupt a lot here
carry a look at his own barrel away Jeff
pulls him right back he's ready to go
from Faker and they find him again
dies to the baronado T1 is fighting back
the Barrett still at 3 000 Acres
definitely
[Applause]
TRX Circle T1 like shocks hurting them
in T1 didn't find a response Goomba can
he steal it
[Applause]
no I think it's fair to say that this
wasn't the cleanest or most technical
finals in world's history like I said
earlier think fist fight as opposed to
duel but in a way that didn't matter
this series wasn't the equivalent of a
600 page textbook on Jungle pathing no
far from it in fact it was a lot closer
to your favorite anime maybe will you be
pointing to it forever as an Immaculate
work of art or a technical achievement
probably not but that doesn't mean that
you didn't still cry at the end that's
where this final truly Shone the stakes
the story the passion and it's those
things that will set this series apart
from its 11 predecessors and however
many come after it plus it wasn't a
sweep which is always great it might be
the best world's final ever and I think
to some people it already is but beyond
that it feels like it has this potential
to sort of revitalize the game think of
how many people watch this great series
and now want even more League action or
aspiring Pros who saw the story lines
and the plays and now want to make sure
that whatever happens in the future at
League worlds they're going to be a part
of it plus most of the players in these
finals were young they have long careers
ahead of them and it's very possible
that they will give us even more
entertaining Series in the future with
emotions running so high it was
heartbreaking to see Carrie area break
down after the loss like I almost had to
stop watching it but it was also
wonderful to see him Embrace Deft his
former teammate from these two teams
hurry up
[Applause]
the tie together both teams left
everything on the field both teams were
basically that Ninja Turtles Meme and
throughout it all I had to remind myself
to take deep breaths regularly like
there were so many moments that
absolutely took your breath away and
seemed impossible ultimately I think
that's what everybody hopes for from a
series like this a chapter that feels
like it belongs that pushes the story
forward and that makes you want to know
where it's going to go next it's not
clear where Deft and Faker will go from
here there had been talk of death
retiring after this tournament whereas
Faker has stated that yeah he's going to
return this final was an unforgettable
night filled with Unforgettable moments
it's going to be very hard to top but
the players that will be responsible for
trying are likely going to be the ones
who are fighting alongside Daft and
Faker and for me somebody who's followed
the scene for a while now that's the
most exciting part about all of this we
had an incredible finals but here's to
many more
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring the notification Bell for Unique
bite-sized videos you won't find
anywhere else hit us up on our Twitter
Instagram Facebook and tick tock